We've been waiting for you
I'm just trying to make my city a better place
Hey Youtubers it's Charlie
So there is a new Daredevil Netflix teaser for season 2
But it's a very different kind of teaser
Really just teasing the fact that Netflix is now almost like the biggest content provider worldwide
I did a video the other day about how Netflix might end up dropping Daredevil season 2 the same day that Batman V Superman hits theaters worldwide
And just to count it up like the big thing they want to hype up with this teaser, not only you know Daredevil, but the fact that they are now in more than 130 countries worldwide
So just to put that into perspective, if they were to make some sort of content like say a new Daredevil series
They could drop it and instantly worldwide everybody could watch it at the same time
Its just like me posting a Youtube video
That's really what gets me exited
Now Netflix is talking about doing a couple of other big things
You know like providing less graphic versions of their shows
Which I think is kind of weird but as silly as that sounds I'm always more happy if more people are going to watch a thing
Its just means more people that can pile in and talk when I make Daredevil videos
Like "oh my god I cant believe the Punisher is so amazing"
Obviously the punisher will be a character that they would have to tone down if they were going to do less graphic version
I can't imagine how they would deal with a Punisher series if they were to try to make that less graphic
But I guess there have been PG13 Punisher movies so if they can do that then they can probably do a less hard R version of Punisher for Netflix
Really I think the biggest barrier, and this is a problem for me too, is the language barrier
Like even if you subtitle things, sometimes there are certain phrases that just do not translate into other languages
And then there's always cultural differences
You know different cultures have their own jokes that are culture specific
So you guys actually let me know like if you've ever seen a Marvel movie in a foreign language
Just let me know  like if there are any jokes that just did not work because they don't translate into your language
Sometimes when they're doing dubs of really, really big movies like Star Wars for example, they can make subtle changes to fix that
But it doesn't always work sometimes it ends up being pretty hilarious
But if you are someone who really likes to help out with subtitles there's actually like a Youtube process if you wanna submit foreign subtitles on videos that I make
You have to go in through the subtitle menu here
but there is something that lets you add subtitles the only real requirement is that there have to be English subtitles first
so if you don't see English subtitles and you wanna help out you can totally submit subtitles
If you really want some laughs though turn on the Youtube auto subtitles  sometimes they're hilarious sometimes they just don't make sense
They're just jibberish but sometimes they wind up being amazingly unintentionally funny
I guess as much as launguage is a barier to getting some of these shows out to like different places around the world really it's China that a lot of film and TV studios are trying to work with next
I mean they've been doing it for a long time but because China's cinema is state controlled they only allow I think it's about 20 foreign films in per year
And that short list of films includes big blockbusters like Star Wars, Avengers: Age of Ultron, Captain America: Civil War
So if you're a film studio and you want your film to make money you know you obviously release it in as many countries as possible
But there's a billion people in China, that's a lot of people that could buy a lot of movie tickets
So if you can get in into China it's a big deal
Which is why sometimes they make HUGE edits to the film because China is really specific about stuff they allow in the country
Like ghost stories is a really good example of something that they hate. Their government really does not like supernatural stories
So if you lived in China and you wanted to see one, you would probably have to pirate it
Which is actually another reason why Netflix and Youtube are so awesome
Like Daredevil season 2, when that drops, it drops everywhere instantaneously, which is probably the best tool against piracy
Now you might live in a country where Netflix doesn't exist so we will not judge you if you have to pirate Daredevil season 2 just to watch it
But thats why I always get really exited when Youtube rolls out in new countries
Now the interesting thing about Netflix and Youtube, they're just 2 examples, Facebook does it too, but they tune their algorithms for culturally specific things
So if there's a big thing happening in your country, you're more likely to see that on like the Youtube front page than something that's happening in America
But like if youre subscribed to my channel you know wherever you live in the world within like a minute or two of me posting a video you'll see it in your sub box
So even if you live in a country where the primary language isn't English
Like you'll still see my videos just like you would see other people's videos
It's just really interesting to see how Youtube prioritises things based on country
It was actually a joke that Pewdiepie told a while ago, where he said that he did not make the front page in Italy
Because the most popular thing to watch online in Italy was soccer matches, or football, depending on where you live
I don't know if that's true but let me know in the comments, if you live in a country
Whose primary language is not English but like you watch my videos about the Flash or Arrow like or anything in general, Game of Thrones
Just let me know I'm always curious to see where people are from
In related news, something that always translates well into foreign languages giant freaking shark. There's a King Shark video that I'm gonna make tonight
David Ramsey, the actor that plays Diggle on Arrow, said that the next big Arrow  crossover on the Flash is going to be a King Shark episode
He and Lyla are gonna be going after King Shark
So be sure to subscribe to get that
I'll post that later tonight
Giant freaking sharks always translate well into foreign languages
So while you guys wait for me to post that you can click here to learn about Deathstorm coming to the Flash season 2
So much awesome stuff happening on the Flash this year
And you can click here for all my Daredevil season 2 videos
Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody around the world high five at the same time, worldwide high five. I'll see you guys tonight.
(Avengers theme plays)